Look, we
just saw
how Donald Trump has danced around
or with white supremacists
over the years.
But sitting at a table at his ho
a Lago
with the white supremacists
like Nick Flynt, is,
does that cross some kind of new
Well, look, for most people,
it's crossing a line for Donald
It's sort of another day in the
And I think we've just got to ac
that the president now has sort
the list of celebrities.
This is what you do.
You hang out
with discredited entertainers.
You hang out with neo-Nazis
and you try to make time
with whoever will give you atten
But the fact of the matter
is, it's appalling
when anyone in public life
has any degree of hesitation
about hanging out with those peo
who promote anti-Semitism,
racism and all forms of hate.
What's the impact of it?
What's the impact of a former pr
and the world?
Seeing a former president dining
with an avowed white upon
it is the normalization of hate
We're seeing it again and again.
And think about it.
We're still mourning
those who were shot dead
in Colorado Springs two weeks ag
just because they were LGBTQ.
Two weekends ago,
we had an anti-Semitic attack
nearly averted
right here in New York City,
where men were apprehended
or intercepted at Penn Station
with automatic weapons,
bulletproof vests and knives
who were planning on
attacking a synagogue.
And now this.
This is the normalization of hat
where a presidential candidate
or someone in public life
thinks it's permissible,
again, to spend time
with people who spew prejudice a
So as a civil society, yeah,
what should we do about this?
What is the right response
Well, I think one thing
what we're already seeing
and you're showing
are people, prominent
Republicans calling it out
when a Republican in their own m
promotes hate
because you need to call it out.
What it happens from your own si
Democrats need to call out Democ
Republicans see to call out Repu
But the second thing
is, we've got to cut off the oxy
to these people.
Trump and Nick Fuentes,
they thrive on attention.
We've got to cut it off
and really reconsider
how we even cover these people a
How do you do both though?
How do you call it out
and cut off the oxygen at the sa
I love the way The New York Post
covered his announcement.
They said, Florida
man announces run for president.
That's how we need to treat Dona
not as a credible former politic
but as a discredited
hack again, who weaponized his h
and who uses anti-Semitism
to advance his agenda?
That's not okay.
No matter how you vote,
no matter what
your party affiliation,
there should be nothing partizan
about promoting prejudice.
Interesting.
Marco Rubio and Mike Pence,
we heard part of his response th
They said basically both the sam
They both condemned
the fact that Trump sat
with Nick Fuentes,
but they both also made a point
that they don't think
that Donald Trump
himself is an anti-Semite.
What do you think of those
who choose to make that distinct
I think it's fair to say
that this man whose daughter,
whose grandchildren are
Jewish has a complicated relatio
with the Jewish people.
But when you validate the people
anti-Semitic venom, that's enoug
We can't judge people on what th
We've got to judge them
on what they do, John.
And again and again,
whether it's saying they're fine
people on both sides,
whether it's pretending
like you don't know who David Du
whether it's telling the people
rampaging through the Capitol,
wearing Camp Auschwitz sweatshir
that you love them.
Again, we've got to judge Donald
on what he does
again and again and again.
And it's validated
being the worst elements of soci